[distorted Windows XP intro]
Poods in Hoods: How's it going, bros? Don't worry about the hoodie.
It's all good. I did not cut my hair, okay?
Don't worry about my hair; it's still-it's still blue, still brue, I prom-I promi, 100%.
Don't-I'm here to talk about something that I've wanted to talk about for a very long time.
PewDiePie's Tuber Simulator. Ah-ta-ta-ta-ta. This game is coming out on the 29th of September.
It's gonna be the most badass game you have ever played. You think that you have played YouTuber simulators before,
well this-you haven't played PewDiePie's Tuber Simulator. That's right, we've gone around the copyrighting[short laugh]
This game has been in develop--ment for over a year, baby. This game is so fresh, it's gonna change your life.
This game is gonna be your new best friend in your-in your pocket. Pokemon Go? More like Pokemon uninstall that shit.
Install PewDiePie's Tuber Simulator. This game is the best game you have ever played on your phone.
Best game that has ever gamed. In your gaming life. That sounded legit, right? OK, great.
Now, you hyped? You hyped for this game? Same guys that made PewDiePie: Legend of the Brofist, the best game in the world-
AFTER this game, of course. This game will be better than that one.
Alright, lets-lets-lets have a look. This is how it looks like. [Reading] Hey, how's it going bros. My name is PewDiePie.
There will be my voice there. I'll teach you how to play the game. But yeah, you start out with your shitty set-up in your shitty room.
You make videos. There is audio in the game, I just can't record both at the same time. I don't know why.
But as you can see, you start off, [sad music starts] and your place looks like a piece of shit; you're a broke-ass YouTuber,
and your goal is to beat me, baby. Your goal is to get more subs than Poopiepie.
Now, we're going to start by making a video. Drinking bleach tutorial. Great.
I did not even set that up. Fantastic. Cat playing piano dies at age 7. That's a-that's a good second video to start with.
So this game plays uh-a little bit like Neko Atsume, if you play that game.
Uh-you pick it up, play it for a while, you put it back in your pocket, and uh-check it about-- a little bit later.
It's a really, really fun gaming experience that I really, REALLY enjoy, and I think it works perfect for mobile.
Umm...oh shit, I keep forgetting to click on Sponsor Eagle. You get shit from him.
As you progress, your studio will become better, you will get better equipment, which leads to better videos, and more views, and more subscribers.
You can move around objects, you can put them where ever you want. This looks shit.
I can customize my self, um, how do I want to look like. Of course I want this outfit.
The fucking coolest outfit ever. FFS, there's so much weird shit in this game. You can be a fucking barrel.
You can be whatever you want in this game, baby. So here's where you can buy items for views. So, you collect, and pimp out your room.
Oh boy, that's a good window. UH-uh-uh-uh. Gotta click on the eagle. Got 5 subscribers. Thank you Sponsor Eagle.
You can choose to play the game passively, like I mentioned, but we also made so that if you WANT to keep playing
you have that option. You can play Puggle, this is actually the first time I've seen the finished version of this, it looks awesome.
[fast-paced dinging]
Oh my god, it's Edgar. Hey, I got the food ball. Hell yeah! There's a skill tree in the game, which lets you strategize-strategize? how you want to get more views
Uh-faster. There's different methods. I like to go for streaming, because that way you can gain views while not playing the game.
Which is pretty cool. Uh-We call it knowledge. There is a fuck load of items in this game. This game is supposed to last you a long time.
This game is gonna be your-your best friend for the next six months; I'm not kidding.
So, if you  don't want to spend any money in the game, you 100% don't have to.
That's the thing everyone kept complaining about when we made Legend of the Brofist.
It's a pretty cool game, yeah, but, uh... it's not fucking free, is it? Well, here ya go, it's free now. You could boost, by watching ads. Don't play those games though.
Um...just play my game. Does it seem sketchy that I'm sitting here with a hoodie introducing this thing?
[creepy voice] Yeah, you guys, you guys better get real hyped for this.
So the goal of the game is obviously to get the most subscribers.
But the way to get that is to get more items, and customizing your stuff. And that's a huge part of the game.
Which is the social aspect of it. I'll tell you what that means.
Basically, you'll be able to vote on other people's rooms. If you really like how someone-how they customized it, you can vote for them.
Or you can follow them. It's basically like getting YouTube subscribers.
There'll be a ranking on all of them-all of this. So it will be a very competitive aspect of the game.
[A few minutes later...]
OK, I literally made this in just like a few minutes, so I could pimp it out a lot more.
But the idea is basically that no matter what kind of YouTuber you would like to make, or which YouTuber you wanna make.
Say here you want to be a YouTuber who...focuses on music, or beauty, gaming. Or funny videos, or creepy videos.
You can make that YouTuber in this game, and uh-customize your set-up accordingly.
[Trade with friends]
And I think that's really cool. I'm so-again, I am so excited for you bros to play this. Heh.
[Chuckles] Alright. So you can definitely get weird with this game. Lets just say that.
Just gotta keep making videos. And one day, you'll be able to beat Poopiepie.
Like I said, it's very creative, so I'm very excited to see how you bros are going to customize your setup.
I just want to say, HUGE thanks to Outerminds for working so hard on this game and making it the best it can be.
It has so many items, so many cool features, it just feels like such a fun game.
I am so excited to see you bros play this. And more than even that, I'm so excited to see what you bros are going to make with this.
It will be open for everyone to play. Fuck yeah(x2). I'm so excited.
[claps] I'm so pumped, are you pumped? 29th. Let's do this. Brofist. I missed. BYE!
[OUTRO]